il est minuit on entend le vent qui
souffle sous mes pieds le sable est
humide mes amis et moi on est sur une
plage bretonne et là un ami me lance le
défi de sauter dans l'eau
à ce moment là j'oublie complètement le
fait que mon corps est à 37 degrés et
l'eau à 10 j'oublie complètement que les
vêtements que je porte sont les seuls
que j'ai pour ma randonnée d'une semaine
j'ai juste un objectif en tête alors je
me mets à courir courir courir courir je
me jette dans l'eau et évidemment 30
secondes après je cours dans l'autre
sens complètement trempé
quelle idée de faire ça
le lendemain sur les chemins de
randonnée Bleach splatch split j'ai
chaussettes encore mouillé
j'ai du mal à ne pas relever les défis
même les plus idiots
j'ai envie de proposer d'autres que je
suis capable j'ai envie de les
impressionner c'est un jeu
c'est le jeu de Lego et ce jeu il nous a
mis un peu tous les jours on cherche à
être meilleur en sport en études en
argumentation dans nos conversations en
culture générale
cet ego on sent que ça veut dire mais si
je vous en demande tout de suite de le
définir
parce que c'est un terme vaste qu'on
emploie peu et qu'on ne questionne pas
la première définition qu'on peut en
trouver c'est l'ego désigne le moi la
représentation et la conscience que j'ai
de moi-même
donc en fait l'ego c'est juste le moi
moi moi moi moi
mais ça ne correspond pas du tout à ce à
quoi moi je pense quand je parle d'ego
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de vous parler de
ce à quoi vous et moi on pense quand on
emploie le terme ego orgueil
arrogance
mépris égoïsme honneur
on pense à quelqu'un qui se sent
supérieur mais pour se sentir supérieur
il faut qu'il y ait des personnes
inférieures
et sans ces autres l'ego des yeux
cet ego
il dépend donc directement des autres de
comment je vois les autres et de comment
les autres me voient
André Gide exprime avec des termes
simples mais d'une véracité
particulièrement énervante
pour moi être aimé n'est rien
c'est être préféré que je désire parce
que j'ai envie d'être la première
personne dans le cœur de mes amis de mes
parents de mes grands-parents de la
personne que j'aime
au fond de moi j'imagine que c'est une
des potentiels raison de la monogamie
historique
quand on met le soja sur la table de la
tromperie dans mon entourage on entend
plutôt un affront qui déshonore qu'un
acte de désamour
et tout ça c'est inconscient j'agis pour
être préféré mais je ne m'en rends pas
compte et lorsque je me rends compte
c'est comme si j'étais prise en flagrant
délit en flagrant délits
c'est un mécanisme en nous qui nous
pousse à vouloir être premier première
c'est un ballon qui se gonfle quand je
suis fière quand j'ai confiance quand je
me sens valorisée mais qui ne nécessite
qu'une simple phrase qu'un simple mot
pour se percer pour se dégonfler
avec mon nouveau gonflé j'ai eu la force
de faire beaucoup de choses
faire des études de haut niveau être
président d'associations être DJ mais
toute cette chose qu'est-ce que c'est
c'est moi qui vais faire les choses à ma
manière ça traduit que j'estime que ma
manière de faire et la meilleure manière
de faire
et pourtant
cette égo il m'a poussé à faire des
choses dont je suis très fière
donc pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
considérer cette Ego comme un moteur une
source d'énergie de motivation
arrêtons le tabou parce que vous et moi
on veut de la reconnaissance faudrait
plutôt que je m'observe que je sois
honnête et que j'aille à la rencontre de
ce qui me motive vraiment
moi j'ai 21 ans
je plus je grandis plus je me rends
compte de ce que je suis dans ce monde
et je suis peu de choses
aujourd'hui j'étudie les sciences du
vivant et de l'agriculture en deuxième
année à AgroParisTech et j'arrive dans
ce monde
un monde en crise en crise climatique en
crise de biodiversité en crise
démocratique un monde qui arrive à la
limite de ces énergies fossiles de son
phosphore de son nitrate et là moi
j'arrive avec mes petites convictions
et elle me crie c'est convictions j'ai
envie de changer le monde
mais sans moi
sans moi le monde ne s'arrêtera pas de
tourner
mais comment sera-t-il ce monde
je me sens incapable je me sens noyé
noyé dans une foule la foule humaine qui
consomme qui conduit qui s'envole pour
Marseille parce que côté 10 euros de
moins que le train est-ce que moi c'est
un plan individu dans cette foule je
suis capable d'impacter ce monde
dans cette réalité accablante quelle est
ma place quelle place pour mon ego
quand je me pose cette question
j'ai juste une réponse c'est
l'impuissance une absence pesante une
absence accablante
pourquoi est-ce que moi j'agirais si je
ne suis qu'une personne parmi tant
d'autres
justement si j'étais une personne une
personne qui pouvait bouleverser la
situation
donc pourquoi pas pourquoi pas avoir
notre ego comme moteur au service de
demande
parce que d'une part on a une crise
écologique une crise climatique qui
nécessite notre action et d'autre part
on a mon ego qui me pousse à agir pour
faire des choses même insensées donc
pourquoi ne pas socialiser les deux
quand j'en ai parlé mes amis ils m'ont
dit
ça me gêne cette idée mais oui ça vous
gêne cette idée parce qu'il y a d'une
part des intentions égoïstes qu'on
considère négatives et d'autre part on a
des actions positives bénéfiques on n'a
pas envie d'associer les deux
pourtant cette envie de valorisation on
l'associe toujours à notre mise à
l'action parce que notre ego nous pousse
à faire des choses donc pourquoi pas
cette association là ce qu'on ne serait
pas un petit peu hypocrite au fond
est-ce que si les intentions d'une
action sont égoïstes ça annule son
résultat non le résultat reste
et je suis d'accord avec vous ce
raisonnement vouloir puiser ma force
d'action dans ma volonté de valorisation
c'est un raisonnement utilitariste
utilitariste parce qu'il se préoccupe
plus du résultat que du moyen mais
est-ce que c'est pas justement de ça
dont on a besoin aujourd'hui de
résultats et vite
merci
cette forme catholique qui pendant plus
de 40 ans de sa vie à consacrer ses
heures aux pauvres laissés pour compte
si vous découvriez aujourd'hui quelles
sont santé glorifié qu'elle s'en sentait
valorisée quel est fière comment la
percevriez-vous
pour moi ça ne changerait rien ce serait
toujours cette femme qui accomplit des
choses que personne d'autre n'a accompli
donc pas de honte pas de honte à vouloir
être valorisé vous voulez être célèbre
vous voulez être le pasteur des temps
modernes vous vouliez laisser votre
trace dans ce monde vous les rendre
votre entourage cher pas de honte et
allez-y alors allez relever ce défi le
défi le plus nécessaire et le plus
difficile de notre temps la durabilité
et ce défi se relève où qu'on soit
de nos champs à nos bureaux de nos
métiers à nos loisirs parce qu'on est
dans une crise systémique
ce qui est problématique c'est notre
manière de penser le monde c'est notre
manière de l'appréhender de le concevoir
donc on conçoit on peut repenser nos
manières de faire nos manières d'être
pour les rendre plus durables
et c'est où qu'on soit et c'est tout
c'est tout parce que dans ma famille
chaque conversation que j'ai avec les 40
ans et plus qui parle d'écologie se
conclut par j'ai confiance j'ai
confiance en Vous la jeune génération va
y arriver
mais
moi il m'en ressortent deux choses de
cette conversation d'une part j'ai un
énorme fardeau je me retrouve seul face
à une crise et d'autre part j'entends
les quarantenaires me dire je ne me sens
pas capable d'agir j'abandonne je me
repose sur toi
mais
à 40 ans on a potentiellement fait
seulement la moitié de sa vie à 40 ans
on a des rôles des postes plus
importants que les jeunes de 20 ans
à 40 ans on a tellement plus de pouvoir
donc allons-y allons raviver cette ego
l'ego des 49 parce que nous aussi on
compte sur vous
et donc si je résume
on a un ego un ego comme moteur qui a
différents mécanismes la volonté de
prouver la volonté de rendre fière la
volonté de reconnaissance
et on peut aller à la recherche de tous
ces ressorts
pour passer à l'action
et vous allez me dire
si c'était la solution on serait déjà
depuis longtemps et c'est vrai et c'est
vrai on serait déjà depuis longtemps
c'était ça la solution parce que si on
veut faire seulement les actes ou du
moins faire croire qu'on fait les actes
on a qu'à faire du greenwashing parce
que dans ce cas là on a la valorisation
sans même se mouiller sans même passer à
l'action c'est tellement plus facile
cet ego c'est peut-être un moteur et moi
si je le laisse filer mon ego sans
orienter sa trajectoire et même droit
dans le mur il me mène vers des actions
qui ne me rendent pas fière des actions
qui me font honte
parce qu'un honneur excessif c'est ce
qui nous empêche de dire pardon
parce qu'un honneur excessif c'est une
entrave dans nos relations humaines or
qu'est-ce que c'est un monde plus
durable
c'est un monde plus collectif c'est un
monde où je partage ma voiture avec mon
immeuble c'est un monde social
le social ça a très conditionné
d'aujourd'hui et l'écologie conditions
de demain or on sait que cette
aujourd'hui elle se demande et sans trop
coupe bien plus que ce qu'on imagine
donc ce social et cette écologie sont
entièrement liées
un monde plus durable qu'est-ce que
c'est c'est un monde où je suis en lien
en lien avec mon environnement avec la
nature avec mon entourage et aujourd'hui
une des expressions de l'ego c'est
que je me sens supérieur aux autres
formes de vie moi humain je ne vais pas
vous faire un dessin ça qui nous a amené
à notre situation problématique
mais comment faire pour en sortir de
cette situation problématique
il faudrait plutôt que je sois humble
humble pour me remettre en question
ample pour aller vraiment m'informer
humble pour savoir qu'est-ce qui a le
plus d'impact dans ce que je fais
faudrait plutôt que je sois humble pour
pouvoir m'associer parce que en
associant je suis tellement plus
efficace
nos collectifs qu'est-ce que c'est
nos collectif c'est des individus c'est
des jeux me moi égoïste et c'est ce jeu
qui a le choix d'agir qui a le choix de
s'associer de considérer le nous fécond
donc à chacun d'entre nous d'aller
prendre notre pouvoir
nos collectifs c'est qui c'est des
politiques des acteurs des décideurs
c'est vous c'est moi
et nous tous et nous toutes on désespère
mais on espère pourquoi parce qu'il y a
des milliards de choses qu'on ne
contrôle pas des milliards de choses qui
ne vont pas dans la direction qu'on
souhaite
donc allons atteindre ce que ce qu'on
peut attendre si on fait en nous la
place pour le changement alors cette
durabilité elle pourra bien plus
facilement sans créer dans nos
collectivités
et s'il n'y a pas la place pour cette
durabilité il va falloir qu'on la crée
parce qu'elle nous est nécessaire cette
durabilité c'est pour nous pour être la
demande dans de bonnes conditions
mais donc pour créer cette place
comment faire parce que j'ai un ego
mais je peux pas non plus le laisser
filer je peux pas être trop en but de
moi-même ni trop peu confiance en moi
parce que sinon je n'arrive plus à
motiver faut que je sois trop haute ni
trop basse qu'est-ce qu'il me faut
il faut que je sois à la hauteur à la
hauteur de mes convictions être fier
d'être à la hauteur fier de garder mon
CAP
et me dire ça ça ne veut pas dire que je
n'échouerai jamais mais au contraire si
je suis solidement attaché à ces
convictions ça sera tellement plus
facile tellement plus accessible d'agir
moi qui suis convaincu
c'est tellement plus abordable toutes
ces actions
et maintenant on me dit maintenant que
je ne venais plus envie de prendre
l'avion tu n'as pas envie d'aller voir
la Thaïlande
mais évidemment la Thaïlande ça doit
être sublime
mais il faudrait que je sois dans un
cadre dans lequel on m'encourage à agir
vertueusement
aujourd'hui ça n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui
on est valorisé pour des actions qui
sont polluantes consommatrices donc dans
notre cadre cette ego et ce besoin de
durabilité ils ne sont pas alignés
comment faire pour être dans un cadre
qui encourage ses actions être dans un
cadre où ces deux choses sont alignées
ben dans ce cas là il faudrait qu'on
puisse tous et toutes faire évoluer nos
vision du monde
et pour cela il faut qu'on change de
valeur
vous allez me dire d'accord ok il faut
qu'on change de valeur mais comment
faire pour changer de valeur pour
changer de valeur on a des outils on a
nos cultures nos lectures nos
discussions
on a cette interaction à l'autre cette
interaction à l'autre qui nourrit notre
ego donc allons creuser ici allons
creuser dans cet interaction à l'autre
mon oncle me reproche le fait d'être
végétarienne et si au contraire il me
valorisait et si au contraire il
m'encourageait
ça serait tellement plus simple de
continuer dans cette voie
et c'est ça la clé
c'est si les autres me valorisent là
alors il me porte et moi aussi moi aussi
si je les encourage si je les rends fier
de ces actes
là alors on se portera ensemble
mutuellement vers notre objectif commun
être là demain dans de bonnes conditions
je me livrais à une amie
parce que je ne me sentais pas là la
hauteur de postuler quelque part
et elle m'a dit non vas-y vraiment je
pense que tu pourras faire quelque chose
de super et grâce à elle je suis ici ce
soir grâce à elle je fais un TEDx ce
soir donc allons-y encourageons-nous
allons-y réapproprions-nous cette ego
[Applaudissements]